now turning to the Middle East where
Muslims worshiping inside a holy site in
Jerusalem fought for a second night with
Israeli police that violence led to more
rocket fire from Palestinians in Gaza on
a night when Jews and Muslims should
have been celebrating holidays Charlie
dagada has the story
[Music]
at their hands -on books stools canes
even the lectern
Israeli riot police opened fire with
rubber bullets once again called in to
force the removal of Palestinian
worshipers intent on barricading
themselves inside the Al-Aqsa mosque the
second night of clashes came just as
Jews began observing the week-long
Passover holiday and right in the middle
of the Muslim holy month of Ramadan
the Palestinian red crescent said six
people were injured
it wasn't nearly on the scale of the
previous night when riot police clashed
with worshipers who police say through
fireworks at them leading to the arrests
of hundreds of people
that triggered Palestinian militants in
Gaza to launch rockets towards Israel
largely intercepted by Israel's missile
defense system and small protests in
both Gaza and the West Bank
the new confrontation that the compound
broke out despite appeals from the
International Community including the US
for calm we remain extremely concerned
by the continuing violence and we urge
all sides to avoid further escalation
it's not just a sensitive time but a
sensitive place the Al-Aqsa mosque is
one of Islam's most sacred sites and it
shares a Hilltop with Temple mount the
holiest site in Judaism it has been a
volatile Flashpoint in the past Vlad
Charlie thank you very much